did you ever wonder what would happen if
muzon sent a different upper moon to the
Mugen train how would the battle play
out and most importantly would rengoku
survive well today we'll be explaining
rengoku's encounter with each upper Moon
starting with the upper Moon 6 kaigaku
if kagaku was the one who arrived
instead of akaza things would have gone
much differently now although kaigaku is
undeniably much weaker than akasa he is
not to be underestimated as he was a
user of total concentration breathing
and mastered a breathing style before
becoming a demon the battle between him
and rengoku would be mostly balanced in
the beginning with the two fighters
fiercely exchanging blows kagaku is an
exceptional user of Thunder breathing
and when that Mastery is combined with
his blood demon art electrokinesis it
would be really hard for the flame
Ashira to keep up with his speed
although kaigaku is a talented swordsman
and a strong foe the one that we see
greatly lacks is experience he is a very
young demon Moon and never had a serious
battle against a hashiro before so he
wouldn't expect Ren Goku's resilience
and would probably underestimate him
after some time during their battle when
Goku would prepare his strongest attack
esoteric art Knight former and Goku at
that point kaigaku would be shocked and
wouldn't know how to react during Goku
would swiftly Dash towards him and cut
off his head before the upper Moon could
even realize what had happened okay that
one was pretty straightforward but there
are still five more battles to cover and
let's continue with the former holders
of upper Moon 6 title gyutaro and Doc if
we want to understand how this battle
would play out we need to look back at
the Entertainment District and just how
hard it was for the Slayers to defeat
them both gyutaro and Doki possess
powers and skills that allow them to
defeat 13 ashiras in total during their
lifetime utero the stronger between the
two has managed to single-handedly
overwhelm the sound to Shear attention
and Powerful demon Slayers like enosuke
tondro and zenitsu however it's not his
poison or strength that make him a
difficult foe to deal with but the fact
that in order to take him down rengoku
would have to cut off the heads of both
siblings simultaneously as both demons
are practically one single body
decapitating both demons at the same
time is a pretty much impossible feat
for a single Demon Slayer and friend
Goku would certainly need some help here
sadly for him Tantra wouldn't be able to
do much as he was already badly injured
from the fight before and zenitsu was
still asleep because of enmu's blood
demon art the battle would start with
when Goku swiftly cutting off doki's
head but as soon as he would do that
utero would emerge from her body the
demons would then take this opportunity
to catch rengoku off guard and land a
few hits on him guitero would rush
towards the unconscious passengers in
order to devour them forcing rengoku to
defend them this would mean that anoski
would have to take on Doki by himself as
he would be the only one capable of
fighting at that time now although docki
is technically the upper Moon her
strength is not really on the required
level so it's likely that anosuke would
be able to stall her at least for a
brief period seeing his friends fight to
the death Tantra would join the battle
and help inosuke at least a bit in
fending off doc okay this is the part
where I wanted to put some funny
subscribe joke to make you guys
subscribe but I couldn't really think of
anything so here's this cool pixel art
of tundra holding a subscribe button so
you could subscribe or not anyway it's a
bit hard to guess what exactly would
happen here but since when Goku managed
to stall akaza until sunrise I think
he'd be able to do the same in this
scenario against utero and the best
thing is he would survive the night even
if kyotaro manages to poison rengoku as
he did with tenjin nazuko couldn't
simply heal him once the fight is over
so far rengoku has managed to survive in
both of these scenarios but from now on
it'll start up get much harder as his
next battle is against upper Moon 5
gilco the upper rank 5 demon gyoko
doesn't seem too strong at first but is
a very tricky one to defeat Yoko has
unique blood demon art which allows him
to create porcelain vases using these
vases gyoko could easily Dodge renkoku's
attacks teleporting himself to a
different location each time the hashira
tries to strike him during the course of
the battle Yoku would probably summon
his fish monsters which spit poisonous
needles however rengoku shouldn't have a
problem dodging these given his
impressive reflexes and speed as the
Fight Continues although renkoku would
hold his ground pretty well against the
demon without the demon Slayer Mark it'd
be nearly impossible for him to land the
final blow the best option for him at
this point would be to try install the
demon for as long as he can but knowing
gyoko's Wicked personality and how short
tempered he is he most likely started
attacking the passengers in order to
mess with ringoku seeing that the
passengers are in danger rengoku would
immediately rush to save them giving
gyoko an opening to use his special
ability called the water prison pot to
trap the hashira similar to how he did
with muichiro the ability is the perfect
prison for breathing technique users as
it suffocates them stopping them from
using their abilities it would be
impossible for rengoku to get out on his
own leaving Tundra and the others to
protect everyone enoski would be furious
and would immediately attack Yoko on his
own knowing that enosuke won't be able
to survive for long Tandra would rush
towards rengoku in order to help him
with his quick thinking Tantra realizes
that breathing into the bubble would
Supply rengoku with enough air allowing
him to perform flame breathing and
Escape however while this is happening
and nosuke would most likely die
fighting as he is known where near
gyoko's level of strength from here on
rengoku would manage to stalk gyoko for
a bit longer until sunrise forcing the
demon to retreat this means that both
rengoku and Tantra would be badly
injured but alive and the only casualty
would unfortunately be a nosuke okay
that encounter didn't really go that
well for the demon Slayers but what
about if rengoku encountered tontengu
would this scenario be any better the
upper Rank 4 demon huntango is a frail
weak looking demon and a huge coward
however once he unleashes his clones he
becomes unimaginably powerful the good
news for the Slayers is that huntengo
isn't impatient and arrogant like Yoko
and doesn't immediately go all out in a
battle instead using his blood demon art
hunting multiplies every time he's
decapitated meaning he starts his
battles weak and then gradually gets
stronger since this battle occurs near
dawn this is perfect for Slayers as they
could just stall weaker clones until the
sun rises the real threat however is on
Tango's final form zohakuten which would
wreak havoc and stopping him would be
near impossible thankfully from what
we've seen during the swordsmith village
Arc hunting will not transform unless
his life is threatened which would only
happen if the Slayers get close to his
real body and that would never happen in
this scenario as the Slayers would be
too busy protecting the passengers from
the Demon's attacks therefore when Goku
and the others would probably survive
till sunrise however if for any reason
pontenku does transform he'd be able to
effortlessly kill rengoku and everyone
else the flame hashira never awakened
his Demon Slayer Mark so there is no way
he'd stand any chance against this
monster before we explain what would
happen if rengoku encountered the
strongest upper Moon kokoshibo let's
first cover what would happen if he
encountered the upper Moon 2 Doma Doma
is by far the most laid-back demon in
the series The Power gap between him and
akaza is evident and if he was sent to
the mujin Train the battle wouldn't last
very long however due to doma's playful
nature he wouldn't take the flame
hashira seriously at the beginning and
would toy with him on the other hand
when Goku would realize that his enemy
is way too dangerous and same as in the
original he would stop Tantra and
enosuke from interfering as time passes
Doma would injure rengoku more and more
and he'd be forced into constant
defensive well aware that his attacks
would do no damage to the demon as the
flame of Shira renko whose main goal
here isn't to win but to stall Doma and
save as many people as possible even if
it cost him his life however despite his
best efforts Doma is quite smart and
would quickly realize what when Goku was
up to this would make the demon mad and
he'd instantly become serious angrily
striking rengoku through the heart
killing him on the spot seeing when Goku
dead tantro and anusuki would be enraged
and rush in to take revenge but they
would obviously stand no chance against
Sirius Doma and would die instantly the
demon would then proceed to devour all
the passengers including zenitsu and
then slowly disappear into the forest
and finally it's time for when Goku to
encounter the upper Moon one kokushibo
second only to The Demon King kokoshibo
is undoubtedly the strongest demon moon
in the series and over the course of 500
years he has honed his skills to their
utmost limits and has countless hashiras
due to him being a Demon Slayer before
transformation he is also a master of
breathing Styles and even has his Demon
Slayer Mark awakened if he was the one
to encounter rengoku during the mujin
train things wouldn't go very well for
the Shira at first kokoshiba would
effortlessly dodged renkoku's attacks
admiring his swordsmanship and breathing
techniques seeing renkoku's
determination and strength kokoshiba
would probably ask him to become a demon
same as a casa did however rengoku would
refuse leading to kogoshibo swiftly
eliminating him in the blink of an eye
seeing her and Goku dead on the ground
Tantra would be shocked and probably
tried to attack kokoshiba using Sun
breathing this technique would trigger
deep forgotten memories in kokushibu and
he'd remember his younger brother
yorishi seeing the image of the brother
he hated in tantro kaposhiba would
become Furious and mercilessly kill
Tundra without saying a word after that
using his Moon breathing he'll kill
everyone in the area before retreating
back into the shadow
it's pretty obvious that the Slayer
stood no chance against kokoshibo here
but did you ever wonder if all demon
moons together can defeat this guy
this got find out